welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is alexander evans a counselor in the
British diplomatic service and a senior
fellow at yale's Jackson Institute for
Global Affairs mr. Evans recently was
the Henry Kissinger chair in foreign
policy and international relations at
the Library of Congress and previously
worked at the Department of State as a
senior adviser first to ambassador
Richard Holbrooke and then to ambassador
mark Grossman the US Special
Representative for Afghanistan and
Pakistan he previously served as a
British diplomat in Islamabad and New
Delhi and as a member of the policy
planning staff in London today we talk
with him in a personal capacity about
the u.s. and South Asia welcome mr.
Evans thank you very much for having me
you've done a lot of writing and
research on the US and Pakistan tell us
a little bit about your findings well
it's it's a really complicated
relationship and a relationship in which
both sides feel often betrayed by the
other side and one of the interesting
things about delving into the archives
particularly of u.s. foreign policy on
Pakistan is to see this theme again and
again right back from the late 1950s
onwards an equally if you go back to
Pakistani speeches and press statements
and Pakistani sources you see the same
kind of story about disappointment with
the United States and disappointment
with relationship the reality is
actually relationships been much more
cooperative than people sometimes think
and both sides have tried to use it to
advance their own national interests so
there's a rationality that underpins
both for us approach to Pakistan and
Pakistan's approach to the US the
trouble is V the issues at Pakistan
sort of a relationship at different
times the subjects that the US has
wanted from Pakistan have changed
depending on what the main themes our
fur for those countries at any given
moment okay and what is the traditional
relationship between South Asia
expertise and policymaking in Washington
I think that the myth of a relationship
between expertise and policy making is
that expertise has very little input
into policymaking MDC I'm not sure that
that's true i think the experts regret
sometimes not being able to be at the
top table when key decisions are made
and it is true that when key foreign
policy decisions are made on on india or
pakistan but they're not going to be
made by a mid-level analyst or the
in-house expert on on the subject but at
the same time i think if you look at the
archives the degree to which principles
so the senior members of cabinet in the
US making decisions about foreign policy
actually drawn advice and analysis but
is deeply steeped in knowledge about
Pakistan or India or Afghanistan
actually expertise has a very key role
to play I think the reality though is
that policy decisions are made by
political principles not by experts and
that sometimes is something that makes
experts unhappy do you think that in
making a policy more more should be
given to the expertise the people who
know about you know what is going on
perhaps no I think it's right in any
democratic society right that elected
politicians and members of the cabinet
make four key decisions on national
security for that country there is a
danger about experts which is experts
can think that they are right more than
they actually are right so they can be
overconfident about judgments that they
make all the analysis that they offer so
actually a little too much expertise can
be a dangerous thing in policymaking
resting are there any is there an
example you might be able to cite
perhaps anything spring to mind well you
know none of the experts it seems that
worked on Pakistan in the 1970s
necessarily anticipated the kind of
relationship the US would have with
Pakistan in the 1980s so experts don't
have any more ability to predict the
future than any of us student than your
I do so the danger is when experts think
that they can predict a future the
reality is that none of us can predict
your future right right and given the
current problems in South Asia including
Afghanistan how do you think the US
should be approaching Pakistan I think
the US needs to approach Pakistan with
serious intent and that means even when
there are frustrations recognizing it
there's a relationship there that needs
to be managed with Pakistan it's far
better to raise problems in private than
engage in the sort of megaphone
diplomacy of complaint and that's that's
a problem that sometimes has been
evident both in Islamabad and Washington
the key over the next couple of years is
that the u.s. still needs Pakistan it
needs Pakistan in terms of the US
counterterrorism interests inside
Pakistan it needs Pakistan in terms of
managing any political process in
Afghanistan but will be really the
underpinning of stability or indeed by
lack of stability in South Asia and
becoming five or ten years that doesn't
mean that you give Pakistan everything
that it wants all that you sugarcoat the
relationship but it does mean that you
have to do business and have a working
relationship one of the suggestions
that's been made has been that Pakistan
should be contained or isolated and that
this is a natural argument given the
frustrations of Pakistan in Washington
but i think you know some of the harder
edged arguments about containing
pakistan neglect to understand the
nature that a the US needs pakistan and
be
Pakistan has other friends China Saudi
Arabia Malaysia turkey and actually
isolating Pakistan on the international
scene would be quite difficult to do yes
it does strike me as as we're in a very
tricky situation so to speak because we
do need Pakistan what do you how do you
think the United States should be
working with Pakistan and what is it
exactly do you think that Pakistan wants
from us well in terms of what Pakistan
wants Pakistan or when when we say
Pakistan we're not necessarily talking
here town all of Pakistan's people but
there's there's a sense of wanting to
have a dignity and sovereignty of
Pakistan respected for Pakistan's
military who've been very much V the
architects of Pakistan's national
security culture and interests they're
very keen to balance or at the very
least offset India's growing power in
the world so it's a very india-centric
foreign policy but Pakistan pursues and
this is something that US has been aware
of right back to the late 1950s and
that's a factor that you we have to
understand properly offer Pakistanis and
what they want in terms of how we
actually work with them I think there
has to be a recognition that of where US
and Pakistan's interests combine and one
of those commonalities is in a peaceful
stable Afghanistan and sometimes where
they may differ but Pakistan may want
the u.s. to be much more active for
example on solving the problems between
India and Pakistan and that's not
something at Washington necessarily
wants to get drawn into so it's a case
of taking a balanced approach but is
conscious of the US national interest
and focused on achieving at but is also
conscious of the style of engagement
with Pakistan and the importance of
personal relationships with senior
Pakistanis and the fact that Pakistanis
in particular Pakistan military and
politicians want to be respected
in international affairs and don't want
to be humiliated or perceived to be
humiliated in my relationship with
Washington how do you how would you
characterize our relationships with
certain individuals in Pakistan today I
think it's no it's no secret but the
relationship has been troubled in the
last year and it's been troubled because
Pakistanis have complaints about
Washington's policies both in
Afghanistan and on terrorism and
Washington has complaints about
Pakistan's apparent willingness or
commitment to support us goals in the
region as well so it's been a troubled
relationship and a relationship that has
also been subject to many shocks so some
of the problems in the relationship
don't come from things that either side
can predict but they come from incidents
or crises for the merge with little
notice and can really derail some of the
ordinary business of trying to build a
relationship together can the United
States influence what happens in South
Asia in the coming years I think this
comes to the heart of the question of
diplomacy you know how much influence
can any one country bring to bear on
another and in fact you know the
question of influence is something I
teach in an undergraduate course here on
diplomacy the u.s. clearly does have
some influence in South Asia one case at
the moment is is the crisis that's going
on as we as we speak in in the Maldives
where some form of change in government
has taken place via the former president
argues that it's a cue the new president
argues that or is a constitutional
change and the US has been very active
Bob Lake the Assistant Secretary of
State has flown out to talk to both
sides and the US has clearly played a
positive role in bringing democracy to
the Maldives not something it gets
international headlines in the new york
times but a very important move for the
people of the Maldives it's more
difficult to see India or Pakistan or
Afghanistan choosing to do things that
are not perceived to be in their
national interest because the u.s.
wants them to do that and so you know
India I think will tread very carefully
in terms of being drawn into a an
alliance with the United States visa V
China Pakistan will be very careful not
to be perceived to do Washington's
bidding in Afghanistan but to pursue its
own interest which are much more linked
as i said earlier to india so the limits
of influence i think really come up to
national interest and it's where those
national interests sometimes are
competing rather than points of
cooperation with Washington okay you
mentioned teaching a course on diplomacy
how are you bringing you know what you
have experienced in the outside world in
terms of diplomacy and policy-making
into the into the classroom well I I'm
really enjoying teaching two courses
here yeah 11 is a graduate course on
South Asia and the other is an
undergraduate course on impact and
influence in diplomacy I think with the
South Asia course the approach I've
taken is to try and use declassified
documents wherever I can in the teaching
of a course so if we're going to discuss
the india-pakistan war in 1965 the trick
is actually saying here as you know
here's the CIA analysis here are the
cables that came in from India and
Pakistan from the US embassies here's
the National Security Council document
debating what should be done by the US
about the crisis wow that sounds like
great fun for the further students well
I hope so and I think it offers a window
into how policy actually takes place
yeah and how it relates back to
impressions that countries have of each
other and and how expertise plays in the
system in a way that perhaps just using
secondary sources doesn't give you the
immediacy of a connection to it in terms
of teaching on on diplomacy we all know
that we're living in a in a changing
world a world where new powers like
China and India and Brazil are becoming
more important on the international
scene and I think trying to build a
course around comparative diplomacy so
looking at actually how do these
countries operate in terms of a
diplomatic reporting network how do
make national security policy what's
their approach not just to the US but
their approach to the wider world around
them and I think that's an interesting
exercise in building a global
appreciation of how states operate and
how some multilateral organizations
operate as well so the courses is much
focused on how Singapore or turkey
operate in the international system as
you know the traditional approaches to
diplomacy which tend to be more focused
on you Britain or Germany or V nited
states so for instance Singapore has a
very different approach to diplomacy
than for instance Britain well Singapore
has a different it has a different set
of national interests and it has a
different size of Diplomatic Service the
Singapore Diplomatic Service is much
smaller than the British Foreign Office
and the Singapore foreign services is an
interesting case in point because they
don't actually have an enormous number
of embassies worldwide but what they do
with a very small number of diplomats is
try and build on relationships with
third countries so in terms of their
relationship with Washington or with
Japan or with the European Union they'll
try and use that to really understand as
much as they can about what's going on
in the world and then actually lobby an
influence on Singapore's key national
interests so I think some of that is is
really interesting the way in which they
invest in talent and qualities foreign
service officers is very striking and
the fact that many of those foreign
service officers don't always stay for a
career many will go off and leave and
work for a management consultancy or an
international bank and the Singaporeans
are comfortable with that their argument
is how do they compete for the best
possible talent to pursue diplomatic
excellence in their foreign policy okay
very good thank you so much for being
here today and sharing some of your work
thank you very much for having me for
more information about mr. Evans please
visit our website at yale edu backslash
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you